J'ai fondé la Sea Shepherd Conservation Society en 1977
comme un organisation luttant contre le braconnage,
les activités illégales en haute mer.
Nous sommes vraiment une organisation anti-braconnage
et nous intervenons globalement
et nous le faisons avec ce que j'appelle l'agression non-violente.
Qu'est-ce qu'une agression non-violente ?
Et bien, nous sommes agressifs mais nous ne blessons personne
et durant nos quarante ans d'existence
nous n'avons causé de blessures à personne.
Mais nous avons fait stopper
de nombreuses opérations de
surpêche, pêche à la baleine
chasse au requin, chasse à la tortue
nous stoppons ces opérations
via des interventions "agressives"
tout en restant très prudents
pour ne blesser personne.
Comment imaginez-vous
le futur des océans?
de votre point de vue, sera-t-il meilleur
ou au contraire plus mauvais ?
Et bien le futur de nos océans,
c'est ce que nous voyons dès maintenant.
Une diminution croissante
de la biodiversité
Nous avons perdu 90% des poissons
depuis 100 ans,
une diminution de 40% du phytoplancton
depuis 1950.
La situation est critique
concernant la biodiversité.
Le problème est que la plupart des gens
ne sont pas au courant de cela.
D'ici 2048, selon le Docteur Boris Worm
de l'université de Dalhousie (CAN)
Et Dr. Daniel Pauly de l'université de Colombie Britannique (CAN)
Qui sont les deux spécialistes les plus avancés
sur l'industrie de la pêche.
Il n'y aura plus d'industrie de la pêche en 2048,
puisqu'il n'y aura plus aucun poisson.
Il n'y aura plus de barrières de corail
Ce que nous prévoyons,
c'est un désastre écologique dans nos océans.
Et cela ne présage rien de bon pour le futur de l'humanité
puisque si les océans meurent,
nous mourrons.
Nous ne pourrons pas vivre sur cette planète avec des océans morts.
Si la vie des océans diminue,
notre capacité de survie diminue.
Mais en même temps, à l'heure actuelle,
malgré votre combat,
L'humanité ne mesure pas l'impact
de la perte de biodiversité des océans.
Alors concrètement, quand est-ce
que les choses vont changer
et comment pourraient-elles changer ?
Pendant des millions d'années
l'océan a été le système de survie de la planète.
Si vous considérez la Terre comme un vaisseau spatial
qui voyage dans l'espace (ce qui est le cas),
N'importe quel vaisseau spatial est équipé d'un système de survie
Et il fournit une source de nourriture, régule la température, contrôle le climat,
et fournit l'air que nous respirons.
Le système de survie de la Terre se trouve dans les océans.
Il est piloté par un équipage qui, sur cette planète,
est composé de toutes sortes d'espèces.
Nous ne sommes pas l'équipage, mais de simples passagers.
Nous profitons bien, mais en réalité nous tuons l'équipage.
Le phytoplancton qui produit l'oxygène, les baleines
qui lui fournissent des nutriments pour le phytoplancton
Les relations inter-espèces
qui maintenaient tout le système en équilibre
depuis des millions d'années
ont été sérieusement compromises,
fragilisant au passage le système de survie de la planète.
et cette situation est très préoccupante.
La diminution de 40% de la quantité de phytoplancton
depuis 1950 est un situation préoccupante,
et cela n'effraie personne.
Le phytoplancton fournit entre 50 et 70%,
possiblement 80%
de l'oxygène que nous respirons,
le reste venant des arbres et des plantes.
Si vous retirez le phytoplancton,
dont la quantité est à l'heure actuelle sérieusement réduite,
nous n'aurons simplement plus d'oxygène pour respirer.
La relation entre phytoplancton et baleines
consiste en le fait que les baleines fournissent les nutriments
au phytoplancton,
essentiellement du fer et de l'azote, via leur excréments,
un peu comme du fumier de cheval
fournit de l'engrais dans une ferme.
Les baleines sont donc finalement les fermiers des océans.
Nous ne sommes pas assez intelligents
pour bien comprendre toutes les inter-relations
et les inter-dépendances entre toutes ces espèces,
à tel point que nous réduisons la capacité de l'écosystème océanique de soutenir la vie sur Terre.
Vous avez certainement entendu parler de la COP21, la conférence des parties à Paris.
A la fin de la conférence, le président d'honneur de la COP, Laurent Fabius, a parlé d'un "accord historique".
Nous sommes maintenant six mois plus tard. Quel est votre avis sur ces accords, et pensez-vous que
la conférence a poussé les gens et les entreprises à réaliser l'urgence de la situation?
La COP21 est un non-évênement. Il n'en est rien sorti de concret.
Ça a manifestement été une très bonne opportunité pour tous les dirigeants mondiaux de se congratuler
et de se prendre en photo en prétendant sauver la planète,
mais ils n'ont pas discuté de quoi que ce soit de pertinent.
J'ai écris un livre sur les solutions pour limiter le réchauffement climatique que personne ne veut entendre.
Ils ne voulaient clairement pas en entendre parler, et ils n'en n'ont clairement pas discuté non plus.
Le fait est que si nous voulons protéger cette planète des conséquences du réchauffement climatique,
nous devons premièrement permettre aux océans de se réparer, c'est à dire stopper toute pêche industrielle,
nous devons arrêter de subventionner ces pratiques industrielles.
Vous savez, ça prend du temps. A moins d'y mettre de la volonté, les océans vont mourir.
Une autre solution est de se tourner vers des régimes alimentaires à base de végétaux.
Nous tuons 65 milliards d'animaux chaque années, sans compter ceux que l'on prend des océans.
L'agriculture animale est responsable de plus d'émission de gaz à effet de serre que toute l'industrie des transports.
Elle épuise également de l'eau, crée des zones mortes,
et est une des causes principales de la pollution des eaux, dans les sols comme dans les océans.
Mais personne ne veut aborder ces solutions.
Ils veulent trouver des réponses... "acceptables", qui ne modifient pas notre mode de vie.
Dans le même temps, les gouvernements passent par des taxes. Ils se disent que c'est une bonne opportunité
de taxer tout le monde pour récupérer l'argent nécessaire.
Mais j'ai remarqué que partout dans le monde, l'argent récolté grâce aux taxes "pour l'environnement"
n'est pas utilisé pour l'écologie, mais est gâché par les gouvernements dans des choses stupides,
comme l'armée, les subventions ou encore dans des salaires.
De vôtre point de vue, la France est-elle impliquée dans l'écologie, ou est-elle complètement aveugle?
Eh bien, la France n'est en rien différente des autres pays.
Comme les autres pays, elle ne fait rien pour aborder les vrais problèmes.
On prétend seulement, au lieu d'agir.
Dans leurs propres eaux, par exemple, la France contrôle le deuxième territoire maritime du monde.
La marine Française a donc une vraie opportunité de lutter contre la pêche illégale,
mais elle ne fait pas grand chose.
En fait, j'ai parlé avec l'Amiral de la marine Française, et il est d'accord avec ça,
mais il dit que ses mains sont liées politiquement.
Que pensez-vous de Nicolas Hulot?
Je pense que Nicolas Hulot est...
...Quand il a organisé la COP21, je pense qu'il s'est rendu compte qu'elle n'allait pas fournir
les résultats qu'il espérait. Je pense qu'il a été assez déçu par cela.
A mon avis, il est le seul avec une carrure "politique" en France, qui veut sincèrement trouver des solutions.
Votre organisation, Sea Shepherd, subit quelques critiques.
Par exemple, certains vous reprochent votre manque de tolérance pour les activités de populations pauvres.
Vous avez ainsi mené une campagne à La Réunion pour protéger les requins.
La population locale était perplexe car il était question de quelques milliers de requins, alors que des bateaux
français pêchent des milliers de tonnes de requins chaque année, et vous ne faites pas de campagnes contre eux.
Comprenez-vous et acceptez-vous ces critiques?
Concernant la première question: nous ne visons que ceux qui agissent illégalement.
Je me fous qu'une personne soit riche ou pauvre. Si elle enfreint la loi, nous nous opposeront à elle.
Ceci-dit, l'essentiel de notre activité est de nous confronter à de grandes campagnes de pêche industrielle.
On parle ici de corporations multi-millionnaires qui pillent littéralement les océans.
En ce moment-même, l'un de nos bateaux travaille en partenariat avec le gouvernement du Gabon
pour stopper la pêche illégale dans les eaux Gabonaises.
La semaine dernière, nous avons arrêté trois bateaux chinois qui pêchaient en toute illégalité.
Le mois dernier, nous avons poursuivi sept bateaux Japonais... Chinois pardon,
qui pratiquaient le drift netting, dans tout l'océan Pacifique jusqu'en Chine, où nous les avons remis aux
autorités Chinoises, ainsi que les preuves de leurs activités illégales.
Nous travaillons en partenariat avec la marine Mexicaine pour sauver l'espèce menacée de marsouin.
Certes, les pêcheurs qui pourchassent les marsouins sont pauvres, mais ils sont aussi dans l'illégalité.
Nous avons saisi 25 palangres et 42 filets maillants illégaux. Nous les confisquons.
Vous ne pouvez pas utiliser la pauvreté comme une excuse pour ce genre de pratiques illégales.
Sinon, on pourrait justifier la vente de cocaïne ou les braquages de banque par le même raisonnement.
Si vous considérez les océans comme une banque contenant les économies et les investissements pour
le futur de l'humanité, les braconniers ne sont pas différents des braqueurs de banque.
Oh, et à propos de La Réunion.
En moyenne, le nombre d'humains tués par un requin est de sept par an.
C'est d'ailleurs plutôt extraordinaire, si on considère que chaque jour, 300 millions de personnes vont sur les océans.
La probabilité d'être tué par un requin est donc très, très faible.
En réalité, il est plus dangereux de jouer au golf.
En jouant au golf, la probabilité d'être touché par la foudre, ou de mourir d'une piqûre d'abeille sont plus grandes.
Il y a plus de morts sur les terrains de golf chaque années que d'attaques de requins.
Nous avons besoin des requins. Ils ont modelé l'évolution de nos océans pendant 450 millions d'années
Ils sont au sommet de la chaîne alimentaire, et sont essentiels à l'intégrité écologique des océans
Il n'y a donc pas d'excuse pour les tuer.
Le problème est que les trois lieux où les attaques de requins sont les plus courantes sur Terre,
sont le QueensLand (N-E Austalie), l'Ouest de l'Australie, et l'île de la Réunion.
Ces trois endroits ont une chose en commun : des programmes d'extermination de requins.
En l'espèce, ils tuent des requins et sont subventionnés par les gouvernements locaux pour le faire.
Les requins sont des animaux territoriaux. Du coup, quand vous tuez des requins dans une zone précise,
Vous créez un vide qui attire plus de requins qui, par leur nature territoriale, deviennent très aggressifs,
car ils essayent de se placer avantageusement dans ce nouveau territoire.
Ainsi, ces programmes dans ces trois zones créent des requins agressifs.
La responsabilité des attaques de requins devient revient maintenant à ceux qui tuent les requins.
Le gouvernement Français, en fait, contribue aux attaques de requins.
Quant aux surfeurs qui se plaignent de cela... Nous avons la chance d'avoir
au sein de notre conseil consultatif Kelly Slater, probablement le surfeur le plus connu du monde.
Et je pense que son conseil aux surfeurs de La Réunion est plutôt approprié.
Il leur a dit : "Si vous avez peur des requins, restez hors de l'océan. Vous n'êtes pas à vôtre place."
Pensez-vous que Greenpeace pèse suffisamment pour influence des décisions politiques en Australie?
Greenpeace est un business, tout comme la WWF
Ils vendent du bon sentiment
Rejoignez Greenpeace, vous serez une partie de la solution
Vous n'êtes pas une partie du problème
L'année dernière, Greenpeace ont réalisé 375 millions d'euros
Ils ont dépensé 170 millions d'euros pour gagner cet argent
C'est un retour sur investissement
ils ont 3 bateaux, c'est vraiment très peu
L'année dernière, SeaSheperd a acheté pour 12 millions d'euros
Nous avons tout le temps 9 bateaux à l’extérieur
Et on en fait toujours plus
Parce qu'on s'est rendu compte il y a longtemps
que l'argent n'est pas la solution.
C'est la passion, l'imagination, le courage des volontaires qui s'impliquent.
Alors on ne dépense rien pour faire de l'argent.
Et l'argent que l'on gagne, on le dépense dans le programme pour en faire plus
Tout le monde sait que vous n'êtes pas sur la même longueur d'onde avec Greenpeace
mais certains de vos abonnés vous suivent tout deux,
Greenpeace et vous.
Ils pensent peut être que vous êtes complémentaires
Est-il possible d'imaginer un partenariat
ou allez vous continuer à vous concurrencer ?
Premièrement, nous ne combattons pas Greenpeace,
nous attaquons les attitudes.
Lorsque Greenpeace soutient le braconnage des phoques,
Nous nous y opposons à eux.
Lorsque Greenpeace soutient la pêche à la baleine,
Nous nous opposons à eux.
Lorsque Greenpeace soutient la chasse aux ours polaires,
Ils ne sont pas du même côté...
Si vous soutenez le braconnage commercial des phoques,
vous n'êtes pas de notre côté.
C'est cela que nous contestons.
Je ne conteste pas Greenpeace en tant que tel.
Je conteste leurs prises de positions.
Des positions que nous réfutons, et il en est de même avec la WWF.
Nous travaillons principalement avec
des associations locales implantées partout dans le monde.
C'est de là que que l'on tire la vrai force du mouvement écologiste.
Dans toute cette diversité.
Vous savez, il y a environ 3 millions
d'organisations écologiques non-gouvernementales
répertoriées à travers le monde.
Et ça, c'est la force de tout le mouvement.
Pas de grosses organisations,
mais toutes ces petites associations sont celles qui font vraiment la différence.
Ce ne sont pas celles qui détiennent les capitaux mais celles qui agissent par passion
Et aussi celles avec qui nous travaillons de concert
Quel est votre sentiment concernant la jeune génération ?
Pensez-vous qu'ils s'inquiètent de la situation ?
Ou sont-ils en situation de renoncement?
Sont-ils conscients de la situation actuelle?
Et bien il s'agit d'un mélange de tout ça
Les jeunes sont certainement bien plus conscients aujourd'hui
qu'il y a 20, 30 ou 40 ans.
En 1972, personne ne savait ce que le mot "écologie" signifiait
Et certainement que les personnes étaient aveugles face aux réels problèmes.
Donc je pense que les jeunes sont beaucoup plus conscient maintenant.
Sont ils impliqués? Oui les gens sont distraits par tout
des jeux vidéos aux amusements
Mais je vois un niveau d'implication probablement
Probablement le plus important de l'histoire
Les jeunes font face au challenge le plus intimidant
que les générations précédentes n'ont pas eu à gérer
Et ce challenge est que nous n'aurons plus
une planète vivable à la fin du siècle
Et cela va affecter sévèrement leur vie !
Donc les obstacles sont vraiment réels
et parfois particulièrement accablants.
Je dois croire que quand on fait face à une situation impossible
et des évidences accablantes
vous devez trouver des solutions impossibles.
je crois que ces solutions peuvent être trouvées
A nouveau, au travers de l'imagination
passion et courage
et je vois cela de plus en plus chez les jeunes.
Nous avons neuf bateaux
Sur ces bateaux, nous avons actuellement
cent vingt cinq volontaires de vingt cinq nations
Ça dépend
Nous avons des milliers de personnes qui veulent participer
Donc je vois la passion des gens qui veulent être impliquées
Ils veulent s'impliquer parce quand ils rejoignent nos vaisseaux
ils ont la satisfaction de voir des résultats !
pour les exemples
ils vont fermer une pêcherie illégale
ils vont sauver des baleines
ou bien des tortues sur la plage au Costa Rica
Ce sont de vrais résultats
Et ça donne aux gens, non seulement la satisfaction de faire
mais aussi l'encouragement à faire plus.
Parce que je crois que chacun a les capacités de changer les choses
de changer le monde
Et on encourage ces initiatives personnelles
ces réflexions personnelles pour trouver des solutions
Les gens paient-ils pour participer ?
Non
Ils montent à bord du bateau et bénéficie d'une cabine.
Ils n'ont pas à payer pour venir
Le seul paiement, c'est le vol pour rejoindre le bateau qu'importe où il se trouve dans le monde
Si c'est en Autralie, ils prennent un vol pour l'Australie,
Si c'est en Afrique, ils prennent pour l'Afrique
Il n'y a pas de coût nécessaire
En fait, nous n'avons pas de frais d'adhésion dans la Sea Shepherd
Nous avons des gens qui nous soutiennent mais pas d'adhésion officielle
Quel serait votre conseil pour les jeunes générations?
Mon conseil serait, avant tout, de suivre ses passions
D'aller au bout de ce qui les intéressent.
Vous savez, j'ai découvert que l'engagement d'un seul individu peut changer les choses
Parce que grâce à Dian Fossey, des gorilles femelles ont survécues au Rwanda
Le travail de Jane Goodall qui protége les orang-outans en Indonésie
Ce sont de parfaits exemples de personnes qui impactent le monde
Grâce à leurs passions
Un homme des Bermudes
Grâce à lui et son action
L'espèce d'oiseau océanite-tempête a échappé à son extinction
C'est vraiment quelque chose d'exceptionnel et une grande contribution de permettre la survie d'une espèce entière
Et j'encourage tout le monde à travers le monde
Quand ils viennent à moi et me disent : " je suis vraiment préoccupé par la protection des jaguars" et qu'ils y croient
Je leur dis de se lancer
"Faites tout ce que vous pouvez"
"Utilisez votre imagination"
"Trouvez un moyen de vous engager pour cette cause"
C'est véritablement ce qu'on tente de faire: encourager les gens à suivre ce qui les animent
Bientôt il y aura des élections présidentielles aux États Unis (US)
Pour vous, qui pourrait être le meilleur candidat pour défendre les questions écologiques?
Ah ah il n'y en a aucun !
Ça serait comme essayer de choisir entre la peste et le choléra, vraiment.
Il n'y a pas de "meilleur" candidat
Qui serait le pire? Le pire candidat?
On a le choix entre un idiot (Donald Trump) ou une psychopathe (Hillary Clinton)
C'est simplement votre choix.
Le problème est que les États-Unis
ne sont pas une démocratie mais une oligarchie
et ils choisissent déjà le président
avant même que les gens ne votent.
J'ai personnellement soutenu Bernie Sanders
et je crois qu'il aurait pu gagner
s'ils n'avaient pas truqué les élections contre lui.
mais aussi, parce que les médias refusaient de le couvrir
parce que les médias sont contrôlés par les mêmes personnes,
qui contrôlent les corporations
qui décident qui deviendra président.
Par conséquent, vous ne pouvez pas avoir
une quelconque représentation démocratique
dans un pays où les corporations ont le dernier mot.
et c'est vrai pour à peu près tout.
Par exemple, Justin Trudeau
est venu à Paris un mois après avoir été élu en tant que Premier ministre canadien.
(Justin Trudeau du Canada)
Oui. Un mois après avoir été élu Premier ministre, il est venu à Paris
et il
Il ferait vraiment quelque chose concernant le changement climatique.
Je veux dire... Il est vraiment idéaliste et il a emmené 150 personnes avec lui.
Et ils se sont tous assis et ils étaient très très impliqués.
Et puis, il est rentré chez lui.
Mais il n'était Premier ministre que depuis un mois.
Donc quand il est rentré chez lui, les gens qui contrôlaient vraiment les choses
l'ont fait asseoir et lui ont parlé.
Car dorénavant, il soutient le pipeline, il soutient le projet <mot manquant> .
Il a dit que les incendies qu'ils ont eu en Alberta ne sont pas liés au changement climatique.
Donc, il est devenu comme tous les autres.
Tout simplement parce que ce ne sont que des marionnettes à qui on dit ce qu'elles doivent faire.
Nous n'avons aucun leader mondial.
Nous n'avons que des marionnettes contrôlées par les entreprises qui, en fait, contrôlent tout.
Les entreprises minières, les entreprises forestières, les entreprises de pêche industrielle,
les pays de puissance nucléaire...
Ce sont eux qui contrôlent tout.
Et le soi-disant "vote"... Ce n'est qu'une mascarade.
C'est pour ça que nous n'avons jamais personne qui fasse vraiment quelque chose.
Il y a un rapport, une pétition sur Internet contre vous car vous avez Brigitte Bardot comme amie facebook.
Que leur répondez-vous ?
Je n'obéis à aucune politique, qu'elle soit de droite comme de gauche.
En fait je trouve ça assez drôle que la droite m'accuse d'être un gauchiste
et que la gauche m'accuse d'être de droite.
Je n'obéis à aucune politique. Je crois que la protection de nos océans est ce que nous avons tous en commun,
au-delà de nos religions, de nos opinions politiques, de qui nous sommes et du lieu où l'on vit...
Nous avons tous cet intérêt commun, qui est de sauvegarder nos océans.
Donc je ne me préoccupe pas trop de ces concepts anthropocentriques, auxquels les opinions politiques et les religions renvoient.
Ce que nous avons fait depuis quelques millénaires, c'est de créer ce système où nous devons nous déclarer les "Êtres suprêmes",
un peu comme des "esprits divins".
Et rien d'autre ne compte. Nous sommes en charge de tout. Nous sommes plus importants que tout.
Je n'y crois pas. Nous ne sommes pas plus importants que tout.
En fait les vers de terre, les arbres, les abeilles sont plus importants que nous.
Car ils peuvent vivre sans nous ; nous ne pouvons pas vivre sans eux.
C'est ce qui fait qu'ils sont plus importants que nous.
Donc je ne m'investis pas dans la politique. Tout ce que je sais sur Brigitte Bardot, c'est qu'après trois ans,
nous essayions de faire prendre conscience du massacre des phoques à l'Est du Canada.
Personne ne s'en souciait.
C'est là que j'ai appris la leçon : si vous voulez attirer l'attention des gens, vous devez jouer avec les règles que les médias imposent.
Et les médias ne comprennent que quatre choses : sexe, scandale, violence et célébrités.
Donc si vous voulez une histoire, vous devez incorporer ces éléments dans l'histoire.
C'est pourquoi certaines personnes disent que vous êtes sexiste.
Eh bien, personnellement, je me fiche de ce que ces gens pensent.
Je ne suis pas là pour les satisfaire
Mes clients sont les baleines, les tortues, les phoques, les requins, les oiseaux...
Je n'en rien à foutre de ce que les gens pensent de moi. Je ne suis pas là pour les représenter.
Faites-vous confiance aux gens ?
Non. Pas du tout. Mais le fait est que...
Dites-moi pourquoi
Pour commencer, laissez-moi juste finir ce que je disais à propos de Brigitte Bardot.
Pardon.
En emmenant Bardot à la banquise, nous garantissions une couverture mondiale.
Une photo d'elle est apparue dans chaque magazine.
En nous avons fait plus avec sa seule visite sur la banquise qu'en trois ans d'activisme.
C'est là que j'ai réalisé que nous devions utiliser des célébrités car ils sont médiatiques.
C'est une sorte de "hacking", de "hack" ? Vous savez ce que c'est qu'un "hacker" ?
Hacker ?
Vous pourriez appeler ça comme ça bien sûr.
Serait-ce une sorte de prise d'otage médiatique?
Oui, en quelque sorte
Vous savez, il y a 6 mois, j'ai lu un discours destiné au gouvernement Russe
Ils n'allaient pas m'écouter !
Mon but était de les convaincre d'arrêter les transports de viande de baleines à travers les eaux de l'arctique
Donc j'ai écrit un discours et j'étais en compagnie de Pamela Anderson pour ce discours en Russie
Et non seulement ils nous ont écoutés mais ils ont effectués une standing-ovation et agit en conséquence
Pourquoi ? Parce que Pamela Anderson représente une forme de média
Et donc nous en appelons à des célébrités et elles sont d'accord pour être utilisées comme un média
C'est donc pourquoi nous travaillons ensemble
Et je ne suis vraiment pas intéressé par qui sont ces politiques et célébrités
Je suis intéressé par le fait qu'ils sont
comme une espèce de chaîne TV
ou un journal
C'est-à-dire, une façon de délivrer un message.
Quelle est votre opinion concernant Poutine ?
Il est comme tous les leaders mondiaux
Je n'ai pas...
C'est une marionnette ?
Ils sont tous les marionnettes d'une autre, vous savez.
Poutine l'est probablement moins
quand vous prenez en compte le fait
qu'il est un dictateur qui s'est imposé de lui même.
Mais qui sait vraiment qui tire les ficelles. Je ne sais pas.
Ce que je sais c'est que...
Aucun réel changement ne viendra des politiques.
Peu importe le type de gouvernement,
ils sont tous redevables du statu quo économique.
Ils sont tous dans l'investissement à court terme,
dans un jeu à court-terme.
Je n'imagine pas qu'un seul leader politique dans le monde
prenne du recul sur les 100 prochaines années et se demande
"À quoi notre monde va-t-il ressembler ?"
À cause de tout ce que nous faisons en ce moment.
Je ne connais aucun d'entre eux qui le fasse.
Quelle est votre opinion sur l'arrêt de la croissance (humaine) ?
Vous savez, aucune espèce sur Terre n'a jamais survécu en dehors des trois lois de l'écologie.
La première est la loi de la diversité.
La force d'un écosystème est liée à la diversité qui le compose.
La deuxième est la loi d'inter-dépendance.
Les espèces au sein d'un écosystème sont dépendants les uns des autres.
Et la troisième est la loi des ressources limitées.
Il y a une limite à la croissance.
Une limite à la capacité porteuse (de l'écosystème).
Ce que nous, humains, sommes en train de faire...
...c'est voler la capacité porteuse d'autres espèces.
Elles doivent disparaître pour faire de la place pour de plus en plus d'humains.
Cela diminue l'inter-dépendance et la diversité.
Ce qui peut conduire à l'effondrement de tout le système.
Si cela arrive ?
Si on doit vivre cet effondrement...
... que va-t-il se passer ?
Que se passera-t-il en cas d'effondrement ?
Notre civilisation cessera d'exister.
Nous pourrions disparaître.
C'est assez simple.
Parce que nous ne pouvons pas survivre sans oxygène,
nous ne pouvons pas survivre sans nourriture,
nous ne pouvons pas survivre en fuyant le changement climatique.
Par conséquent, nous ne survivons pas.
C'est malheureusement la conséquence finale.
Le seul moyen de survivre est d'apprendre à vivre en harmonie
avec toutes les espèces peuplant cette planète.
Nous devons tous nous en rendre compte et comprendre
le rôle qu'elles jouent.
Le rôle des baleines, le rôle des poissons, le rôle des oiseaux.
Ils contribuent tous au maintien de l'écosystème.
On ne peut pas continuer à agir
comme si nous étions la seule espèce qui compte.
Que pouvez-vous nous dire de l'équipe Cousteau ?
Commençons par le Capitaine, puis parlons de la jeune génération.
J'ai connu Jacques Cousteau et je l'ai rencontré à diverses occasions et...
je pense que c'était un homme en avance sur son temps.
Il a certainement énormément contribué à l'éducation mondiale sur les écosystèmes marins.
Donc en tant qu'éducateur, il a vraiment été...
...il a beaucoup contribué (à la cause).
Et la jeune génération ?
Je ne m'entends pas très bien avec Jean-Michel Cousteau.
Mais avec les enfants...
...les petits-enfants, je m'entends bien avec eux.
J'ai discuté et travaillé avec eux, et je pense que...
...c'est une famille très symbolique concernant...
...la sensibilisation aux problèmes océaniques.
Et je suis vraiment heureux de voir qu'ils sont engagés.
Vous savez, toute la famille est engagée d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Et ils apportent une contribution.
Je les apprécie beaucoup.
Avez-vous vu ce qu'on appelle le "septième continent" ou le "vortex de déchets du Pacifique nord" ?
Je sais à quoi vous faites référence.
Nous avons eu une campagne de sensibilisation sur le plastique qui dure maintenant depuis des années et qui est appelée le "Projet Vortex".
Et nous agissons : nous avons des plages de nettoyées aux quatre coins du monde,
nous ramassons des tonnes et des tonnes de plastique dans le monde entier et nous le mettons à recycler
(nous envoyons le tout à un centre de recyclage).
L'année dernière, nous avons rassemblé 72 kilomètres, 70 tonnes de filets venant de mers du Sud de la planète.
Et nous avons transformé ces filets en chaussures.
Et nous cherchons aussi des solutions alternatives au plastique.
En ce moment même, nous avons un projet pour trouver des solutions alternatives aux pailles en plastique.
Et nous travaillons aussi avec une entreprise de Saint-Malo qui fabrique du plastique à base d'algues, ce qui le rend biodégradable.
Donc c'est une combinaison de nettoyage, de dissuasion de l'utilisation du plastique et de recherche de solutions alternatives au plastique.
C'est un grand projet pour Sea Shepherd.
Que pensez-vous de Fukushima ?
Eh bien, Fukushima est une chose dont les gens ne veulent pas vraiment parler car...
Je veux qu'on en parle !
Oui je sais. Mais en général. En général, ils ne veulent pas en parler car
il n'y a pas de solution à ce problème.
Les Japonais essaient de cacher l'ampleur des dégâts.
Mais les dégâts sont immenses et ils continueront de l'être.
L'eau radioactive s'infiltre dans les nappes phréatiques, et à Tokyo, ils la rejettent dans la mer.
Nous en constatons les effets sur les poissons de la côte californienne et certainement en Alaska.
C'est une grande, grande tragédie qui a été minimisée par les médias du monde entier.
Mais le problème de cette situation, c'est : comment y faire face ?
Vous ne pouvez pas vraiment nettoyer.
Mais ce que cela annonce...
...c'est que cette situation se reproduise dans d'autres endroits du monde.
Juste la semaine dernière,
la centrale nucléaire californienne Diablo a été fermée.
Nous avons tenté d'obtenir cette fermeture durant des années...
...parce qu'elle est construite au croisement de deux failles sismiques.
Ils ont construit un réacteur nucléaire au-dessus de deux grandes failles sismiques.
Donc ils l'ont fermée.
Comment vont-ils la démanteler ? Je ne sais pas.
Mais on est en train de réaliser que ces centrales nucléaires peuvent causer de vrais dégâts...
...à chaque fois qu'il y a un accident...
... comme Tchernobyl ou Fukushima.
Et en seulement une génération...
...nous avons eu deux, presque trois accidents nucléaires majeurs.
Et ça n'annonce rien de bon pour le futur de l'énergie nucléaire dans le monde.
Que pensez-vous de la politique nucléaire française ?
Je suis de fait opposé aux centrales nucléaires.
Mais, vous savez...
Le problème c'est vraiment que...
Vous avez une population de 7.5 milliards.
Comment leur fournissez-vous de l'énergie ?
Il y a le nucléaire, le charbon, le pétrole, les éoliennes...
Mais le problème
c'est que toute notre population mondiale est dépendante des énergies fossiles.
Les gens pensent que l'énergie nucléaire est "propre".
Elle ne l'est pas.
C'est au contraire une utilisation très intense d'énergie fossile.
Parce que pour faire une once d'uranium...
....vous avez besoin de mille tonnes de minerai.
Ce qui veut dire que vous devez la miner, la broyer, la transformer, la transporter...
La quantité d'énergie fossile utilisée dans l'industrie nucléaire seule
surpasse presque celle utilisée dans l'industrie du pétrole et du charbon combinée.
Donc ce n'est pas une énergie propre.
C'est une fantaisie d'affirmer que c'est une énergie propre.
Mais...
Le vrai problème c'est qu'il y a beaucoup trop...
...de consommation d'énergie par beaucoup trop de monde
via des produits qui sont essentiellement inutiles.
Nous devons nous débarrasser des produits inutiles.
Nous devons trouvez des moyens d'arrêter
l'expansion démographique de manière responsable.
C'est, en quelque sorte, la théorie de Thomas Malthus ?
Oui.
Qu'en pensez-vous ?
Ça l'est, mais, la population ne va pas grandir au delà de 12 milliards, c'est la limite.
Parce que ça va s'effondrer avant cela.
C'est juste que la planète ne peut pas...
Supporter ?
Supporter 12 milliards de personnes.
Ça ne va pas arriver.
Et cela va se passer avant la fin du siècle. Ça va s'effondrer.
Et.. Je suis absolument convaincu de ça. Maintenant, la solution est compliquée
mais, vous savez, ce que je trouve vraiment frustrant, c'est quand les gens intelligents disent :
"Je ne vais pas avoir d'enfants, car je ne veux pas contribuer à ce problème."
Mais ils représentent moins de 3% des gens qui sont assez au courant pour dire ça.
Et, ces gens devraient plutôt avoir des enfants
Vous savez, sinon on élève juste des générations et des générations de gens qui n'ont absolument aucune conscience du tout.
En fait je crois qu'il y a un bon film qui s'appelle "Idiocratie"
Dans lequel, dans 500 ans, nous vivons dans un monde de gens stupides
Mais, il n'y a pas de solutions faciles, mais des solutions doivent être trouvées
Et je pense que nous devons vraiment nous concentrer sur la réduction de la consommation de matières
Et au lieu d'un pays du tiers-monde qui essaye de devenir un pays riche,
Les pays riches devrait chercher à se rabaisser eux-mêmes à un niveau de consommation plus bas.
Êtes vous au courant de la "si cool" théorie qui s'appelle "peak oil"
Vous savez "le peak oil" (pic petrolier)
Quel est votre opinion à ce sujet c'est une théorie, c'est quoi?
Eh bien c'est une ressource finie, ça va s'effondrer.
Et on peut d'ores et déjà l'observer par le recours à des pratiques tel que la fracturation hydraulique
et d'autres techniques non conventionnel qui permettent d'extraire de moins en moins de petrole
Et... le problème avec le pétrole, c'est que c'est une drogue
Et notre civilisation, au complet, est dépendante à cette drogue.
Nous sommes des junkies (des toxicomanes) ?
Nous sommes des junkies du pétrole. Et comme des junkies, nous faisons tout pour l'obtenir
et ça signifie détruire la planète sur laquelle nous vivons, nous allons le faire pour l'avoir
Et si ça signifie tuer des gens dans les pays du tiers monde,
si ça signifie détruire nos océans, on va le faire car nous sommes dépendants à cette drogue.
Regardez les guerres dans lesquelles on se bat actuellement.
D'ici 2030, il y aura probablement une grande guerre sur l’Antarctique
parce que c'est la dernière réserve intacte de pétrole mais aussi de cobalt
et d'autres, du charbon par exemple, 200 mètres de filons de charbon vers les montagnes trans-antarctiques
C'est intact pour le moment mais ils iront le chercher
Et quand ils le feront vous verrez de nombreuses aventures militaires en Antarctique
Donc les guerres du XXIème siècle seront des guerres pour les ressources
Mais pas seulement pour le pétrole, pour l'eau également
Il y aura d'importants conflits pour l'eau et sa disponibilité
Donc d'une certaine manière le réchauffement climatique aide les grandes entreprises
à trouver du pétrole en Antarctique?
Oui cela sera plus facile. Ce sera plus facile d'exploiter le pétrole d'Arctique
Cela ouvrira également de nouvelles zones de pêches
Ils voient tous les bénéfices
Ils disent: "Vous êtes un écologiste, vous voyez le verre à moitié vide"
"nous voyons le verre à moitié plein."
"Nous voyons que le réchauffement climatique va nous aider économiquement"
Et cela peut être vrai pour une courte durée, puis cela va nous détruire psychologiquement
Hier, la température à Téhéran était de 155°F
Ce qui fait 72°C
Qui peux vivre dans ce genre de situation?
Nous voyons des évidences du changement climatique autour de nous tout le temps
Notre climat change
Et pourtant, les principaux médias populaires cachent que c'est un vrai problème
C'est un vrai problème, et cela va devenir de plus en plus notre problème
Pensez vous que l'opinion publique changerait d'avis sur les problèmes environnementaux
si on était capables de lui présenter un plan écologique
qui serait économiquement viable ?
Hum, qui rapporte de l'argent hein..
et ensuite, pensez vous que les médias aideraient à promouvoir ce plan ?
certainement que les gens embrasseraient des idées
alternatives qui procureraient de l'argent
mais nous avons aussi la suppression de ces idées par
les compagnies pétrolières
et d'autres multinationales qui voient ces idées comme des barrières
pour leurs propres profits.
Donc ce n'est pas facile de trouver et promouvoir ces alternatives
Il y a eu beaucoup d'idées pour des alternatives énergétiques
qui étaient moins impactantes pour l'environnement
mais elles ont été supprimées par les compagnies qui font réellement du profit
et qui les voyaient comme des menaces pour leurs profits.
Elles ne sont pas "juteuses", elles sont justes bloquées par le lobby pétrolier ?
Beaucoup d'entre elles le sont, oui.
Je sais que c'est éloigné de votre sujet de prédilection,
mais je voudrais avoir votre point de vue sur l'Arabie Saoudite,
comme nous l'appelons en Français.
Vous connaissez, l'Arabie Saoudite ?
Oui, j'en ai entendu parler.
Dites-moi, quel est votre point de vue sur ce pays ?
Eh bien, il me paraît y avoir une incroyable hypocrisie.
Par exemple, les États-Unis condamnent
les pratiques islamiques en Syrie, en Iran
et Afghanistan
mais supporte l'Arabie Saoudite,
la seule raison pour laquelle ils font cela, bien sûr,
c'est pour l'argent.
Parce que l'Arabie Saoudite est un partenaire économique,
donc, parce qu'ils partagent la même vision économique,
tout est justifié.
Mais personnellement, je pense qu'un des problèmes
de notre monde, aujourd'hui,
sont les religions anthropocentriques.
Toutes autant qu'elles sont.
Et je pense que le monde serait bien meilleur
si nous abolissions
l'islam, le christianisme, le judaïsme
et tous les autres religions qui disent :
"Les être humains sont le centre de la création,
le centre de l'univers, et les puissantes légendes que nous pensons être."
Nous devons mette un terme à cela.
Est-ce possible ? Je ne sais pas.
Mais ce que je sais, c'est qu'ils sont une racine
de beaucoup des violences et des destructions sur cette planète.
Que pensez-vous de Krishnamurti ?
Krishnamurti ?
J'ai lu l'histoire de la vie de Krishnamurti
et je me souviens que dans les années 1920, il a donné une conférence de presse
où il a dit : "Regardez,
je n'ai rien de spécial,
je n'ai pas les réponses,
en fait, c'est un canular."
Et vous savez ce qu'il s'est passé ?
Il n'a jamais gagné autant de fidèles qu'à ce moment-là.
Et c'est là qu'il a dit : "OK, peu importe, je serai qui vous voulez que je sois."
Mais il réalisa que tout ça n'avait absolument aucun sens.
Il n'y a pas de gourou, il n'y a pas de prêtre,
il n'y a personne qui a des réponses spéciales.
J'ai une question sur le boycott.
Puisque que vous avez dit que
tout passe par l'économie
et que le boycott est une
arme économique, car les gens peuvent avoir un impact
sur l'économie.
Êtes-vous en faveur du...
...boycott ?
Eh bien, oui et non.
Les boycotts sont vraiment très difficiles à organiser,
très chers à organiser,
et... c'est aussi difficile de les arrêter quand ils commencent.
Mais c'est une arme économique valide, oui
il n'y a aucun doute là dessus.
Je veux dire, le premier boycott auquel j'ai participé
était celui de Cesar Chavez qui concernait les cépages Californiens
dans les années 60.
J'ai trouvé que c'était plutôt efficace
pour obtenir de nouveaux droits pour les viticulteurs Californiens
donc Cesar Chavez a obtenu quelque chose avec le boycott des cépages Californiens
et c'est donc ma première expérience avec l'efficacité des boycotts
Il y a un nombre croissant de personnes qui ont fait le choix de devenir végétariens,
"flexi-végétariens" ou végans...
La plupart d'entre eux changent leur façon de se nourrir et de vivre
à cause de scandales sanitaires ou éthiques.
Pensez-vous que changer nos habitudes alimentaires
contribue à la bataille pour sauver la planète et sa biodiversité ?
Je le pense absolument...
Mes navires sont végans depuis 2000 et végétariens depuis 1980.
Car je crois que nous devons donner un exemple :
celui que nous ne pouvons pas sauver le monde en faisant partie du problème.
40% de toute la pêche en océan sert à nourrir les élevages de porcs, de poulets et de saumons.
Quand vous mangez un hamburger, en réalité vous mangez du poisson, donc nous nous nourissons littéralement des océans.
Nous tuons 65 milliards d'animaux chaque année dans l'élevage industriel planétaire.
Les poissons que nous pêchons servent davantage à nourrir nos poulets.
qu'à nourrir les albatros et les puffins.
Les porcs mangent plus de poissons que tous les phoques de l'Atlantique Nord
C'est un comportement qui n'est absolument pas naturel.
Et je crois que l'humanité peut demeurer auto-suffisante sainement en se reposant sur des régimes alimentaires à base de plantes.
Leur production consomme moins d'eau, dégage moins de gaz à effet de serre, sont moins sources de pollution que la production animale.
Donc oui, nous soutenons beaucoup cela, mais pour des raisons environnementales.
Il y a beaucoup de raisons pour lesquelles les gens soutiennent le véganisme, qu'elles soient éthiques ou sanitaires
mais nous le faisons pour des raisons environnementales.
Pensez-vous que les insectes puissent être une partie de la solution?
J'ai été en Afrique, et c'est vrai que cela fait longtemps qu'ils se nourrissent de larves de mouches sur le lac Victoria...
Mais je crois que nous devons comprendre que les insectes jouent un rôle incroyablement important.
Cette planète est maintenue en bonne santé grâce aux bactéries, au plancton et aux insectes. Nous avons besoin qu'ils puissent remplir leur rôle.
Les abeilles assurent la pollinisation,
les vers et les fourmis qui aèrent le sol,
Ce sont vraiment les gardiens de la planète et nous avons besoin d'eux.
Je ne dis pas que tout le monde va devenir végétarien, végan ou quoi que ce soit, je dis juste que cela constitue une alternative certaine,
et particulièrement pour les premières nations du monde pour lesquelles cela n'est vraiment pas une nécessité de se nourrir de steak, de poulet ou quoi que ce soit chaque jour.
Il est difficile aujourd'hui en ville de trouver un restaurant dans lequel vous pouvez prétendre à un repas décent,
cependant nous trouvons de plus en plus d'endroits qui le proposent
et les gens sont en train de se rendre compte que l'on peut tout à fait vivre en bonne santé en suivant un régime végan.
Pensez-vous que le modèle des delphinariums tel que le Marineland
dans lesquels des mammifères marins sont gardés en captivité, touche à sa fin?
Nous travaillons à la fermeture de delphinariums depuis des décennies
et nous faisons beaucoup de progrès.
Nous poursuivons Marineland en ce moment-même à Antibes,
mais nous travaillons également à leur fermeture à échelle mondiale.
En ce moment, il y a 65 orques en captivité,
165 sont déjà morts,
c'est pourquoi nous travaillons à libérer ces soixante-cinq là.
C'est réellement une forme d'esclavage,
exactement comme en Afrique quand les hommes ont tué et réduit les survivants en esclavage.
Nous faisons la même chose au Japon
nous tuons des centaines et des centaines de dauphins,
gardons les meilleurs et les plaçons dans des delphinariums afin d'amuser les gens.
Ils n'appartiennent pas à ces endroits-là. Ils sont extrêmement intelligents,
sensibles, au comportement social complexe,
ce sont des créatures très conscientes
et nous devrions leur témoigner tout le respect qu'ils méritent.
Ils ne sont pas là pour réaliser des tours stupides destinés à amuser les êtres humains.
Dernière question :
Avez-vous des questions à nous poser?
Quel genre de message essayez-vous de délivrer?
Nous essayons de faire en sorte que les gens puissent s'exprimer auprès d'autres.
C'est tout.
Encourager le dialogue autour de tous ces problèmes est important
et nous avons besoin de plus de gens afin d'alimenter le débat,
cependant ce sont également des sujets qui demandent à être discutés autrement
que systématiquement dans un esprit de compétition.
Les gens deviennent très "polarisés" en ce qui concerne leurs opinions.
Si vous avez tel avis, alors automatiquement vous n'aimez pas ceux qui en ont un différent.
C'est un autre problème de la condition humaine,
ce nationalisme jaillissant, probablement hérité d'anciennes pulsions primitives, je ne sais pas...
Il y a quelques années j'ai compris cela.
Il y a un restaurant aux Etats-Unis qui s'appelle "The Medieval Times" ( L'époque Médiévale )
on y sert des plats médiévaux, on assiste à des joutes de chevaliers et ce genre de choses...
Vous n'avez pas vraiment le choix de la place que vous allez occuper,
cela peut être dans la zone bleue, verte, noire, peu importe.
On était assis dans la zone bleue, et ce que j'ai remarqué c'est que
en à peine vingt minutes, tout le monde dans la zone bleue détestait tous ceux de la zone verte.
Tous ceux de la zone verte détestait ceux de la zone rouge et tout le monde applaudissait son chevalier .
En d'autres termes, ce qu'on peut en déduire c'est que le nationalisme naît sans qu'il n'y ait aucune raison.
En quoi êtes-vous français ?
Vous êtes nés en France.
En quoi êtes-vous américains ?
Vous êtes nés en Amériques
Vous savez, c'est la seule différence entre les gens.
Pourtant ils deviennent tous hystériques quand il s'agit de couleurs vestimentaires et...
...sur certaines idéologies
qui, au final, ne signifient...
...rien.
Tous les gens sont, en fait, les mêmes.
C'est pourquoi je pense c'est aussi lié avec la religion
qui, bien sûr, est une autre forme de division.
C'est qui causera la chute de l'humanité.
Ce sont toutes ces divisions causées par ces choses artificielles
que sont le nationalisme et la religion.
Ce serait comme un gigantesque match de football
et tout le monde a une équipe
et chacun encourage les équipes et éventuellement se battent pour.
et c'est ce que nous voyons continuellement.
Paul Watson
Merci
Merci à vous.